bubbles
not that kind we're talking speculative
bubbles that can really tear the global
economy a new one there the worst part
of the boom and bust cycle bubbles
happen when speculators get rich selling
things that turn out to be worth much
less than they claim everyone wants in
on the potential profits and the
government has no regulations against it
take for example the 2008 housing bubble
when banks were handing out mortgages to
people who can never afford them when
all those people couldn't pay the bubble
burst banks had to get bailed out and it
nearly ruined the US economy but
speculative bubbles aren't new the Dutch
tulip bubble or tulip o manias thought
to be the first one tulip bulb went from
being worth as much as a ship's crew
made in a year to being completely
worthless devastating the Dutch economy
the Roaring Twenties led to the wall
street stock market bubble dat burst in
1929 and left behind the Great
Depression with the rise of the internet
everyone wanted a piece of cyberspace
and would pay a lot for it companies
worth a little more than their names
sold for billions on the stock market
and were wiped out when the bubble burst
lots of people lose money off bursting
bubbles so shouldn't we be concerned
about preventing them in the first place
the cost of living in America's cities
has skyrocketed and we're up to our
eyeballs in student debt today those
same schools cost more than